welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
review this is a series in which I
review books usually fairly recent but
sometimes classic that have to do with
practical philosophy in a very broad
sense so encompassing self-help personal
development leadership ethics applied
ethics and all sorts of other things and
the book that I have for you today
is not all that recent but has made a
huge impact it's by Martha npal and it's
called anger and forgiveness resentment
generosity Justice it came out in
2016 is viewed as an important study and
argument about the emotion of anger and
some Allied emotions dispositions other
things that we can talk about including
moral concept
and uh full disclosure up front I have
been using this book as a textbook in
some of my classes fairly recently that
I taught at Marquette University so I've
had the chance to go through the book
not just as a reader but as somebody who
was introducing other readers to key
Concepts using this particular book my
review of it is somewhat mixed as you'll
see in just a bit but let's uh look now
at some of the key ideas and components
that we're going to find in this pretty
decent
book I always like to begin by
concentrating on three thematic aspects
the three s's style uh the structure and
then providing some sort of summary of
what the work is so I think it's you
know in the title itself anger and
forgiveness and I would say that anger
gets a good bit more analysis than does
forgiveness so it's probably good that
that forgiveness comes second and then
resentment generosity Justice these are
some other key ideas that figure in
pretty heavily and what nobal is
actually doing here is sort of
alternating anal Anis and Exposition
with an overall argument that she is
making about the emotion of anger and
its connection with Justice and
Injustice and forgiveness or you know
alternate possibilities like for example
generosity that we're going to look at
here and the overall argument that she
is going to make is that anger is
understandable but not the most
productive or ethically good response
that a lot of people make it out to be
and in fact it often generates all sorts
of problems for you know not only other
people but for oneself and can get in
the way of a number of things that we
really do value and she's going to
explain why she thinks this is the case
throughout the work itself um you know
what we're getting here are insights and
models and analyses and arguments and
even some case studies in part so I
think if we want to look at the
structure itself you notice that it's
set up in a you know fairly standard
academic way and in the very first
chapter in the introduction it starts
out with a you know striking set of
images what can we draw from these and
then goes into the typical in chapter
one in Chapter 2 in chapter 3 you know
laying out what the floor plan if you
like or the itinerary of the book is
going to
be and so what we get here if you look
at this so we have a a first chapter
that's an introduction that's relatively
short in which NOS Bal is explaining
what she's going to do then we have a
longer chapter on anger itself where
she's in engaging in some analysis of
you know what anger involves how it
works um looking at some some case
studies in order to provide some some
useful contrasts right so what she's
doing there is isolating out and
explaining the connection between
different elements of anger as it's been
traditionally understood using uh
philosophers and and many other people
to help with this as as well then the
third chapter is about forgiveness and
so it's engaging in some you know quite
interesting examinations and
evaluations of what different people
have had to say about forgiveness making
a really important distinction between
types of forgiveness that we'll talk
about in just a bit and it's got a an
appendix which is uh connecting it to
you could say religious themes with the
D and then what nelum is going to do
throughout the rest of the work is
examine how anger works or doesn't work
in a number of different settings so
chapter four is called Intimate
Relationships the Trap of anger and it's
focusing on you know family friends
romantic relationships all of those
things that we consider to be really uh
key to our our lives and you know even
if we don't have them we may you're for
them right and most people do in fact
have some sort of personal sphere like
this and then what nobal is going to do
ultimately moving into the much later
chapters is go all the way from the
individual or the household and in some
respect this is kind of like ancient
philosophy right all the way up to the
political and social community that we
participate in and there's going to be
two chapters devoted to that that before
we get there though there is this
longish chapter 5 which is the middle
realm and interestingly it's subtitled
stoicism qualified right and the middle
realm includes all of these things that
are not in the political realm not in
the personal realm all that in between
and we'll talk about that in a bit then
we have two chapters that are devoted to
the political realm one of which is
devoted primarily to law and Punishment
in you know legal operations the
criminal justice system the other of
which is devoted to revolutionary
Justice that is uh anger and its role
that it could play and also forgiveness
in situations of systemic
intergenerational Injustice that has
been going on on a on a political level
for a very long time and needs to be
addressed and then after that we have uh
another short conclusion the eyes of the
world you know bringing things to a
close and then there's three appendices
to the book one has to do with another
book by nusb emotions and her book
upheavals of thought uh another appendix
anger and blame looking a little bit
more closely at that and then appendix
see anger and its species you know which
is a traditional Phil philosophical
Topic in looking at anger how many
different kinds of anger are there so
that's the that's the structure of the
book of course it has an appendix like
uh academic books always do and you know
we're talking about you know uh with the
notes and stuff a little bit over 300
Pages
total now the style um you know nbal is
a great writer I think that you're going
to find it quite easy to follow along
with she uses a lot of examples and
cultural references to help readers out
um the book is from 2016 so of course it
doesn't have cultural references coming
after that we'll talk about why that
matters and just a bit um and and some
of them might appear to you to be a
little bit dated nbal is in fact a
member of that generation we call the
Baby Boomers and does draw her her ideas
from from you know her common experience
as a college well University Professor
the book draws uh on philosophy on
religious literature on drama and poetry
and and novels on psychology on music it
it's drawing on a lot of different
sources and just to give you an idea
about like who are the philosophers that
she's engaging AR plays a big role
senica plays a big role Jeremy benam
Joseph Butler Charles Griswald who's you
know a recent author who's written about
forgiveness uh and then to a lesser
extent we could say John Stewart Mill uh
lanus the great Christian author from
ear early years of uh Christianity Sten
Bernard Williams who the book is
actually dedicated to and we do get some
cuspus but the CPUs is of course coming
through summaries of his work because we
don't actually possess any uh cuspus
works at this time so you know that I
think gives you an idea about those
three 's what's going on in this book
let's talk now about some of the key
ideas so as I mentioned there is we
could say an overall argument to the
entire book which is that we got to
really really careful with anger and
many of the
justifications that people give for it
as something positive when we examine
them according to nusb turn out to be
misguided turn out to uh require too
much of our buying into other things
that are not good for us in order for us
to achieve an effect like for example
defending ourselves addressing Injustice
and she's is going to engage in this by
way of examining a lot of different
experiences uh examples some of which
are drawn from like ordinary life some
of which are drawn from
literature um and uh engaging with a lot
of people's already
articulated ideas positions arguments
about anger itself and so you know she's
stepping into a long discussed um we
could call it Arena of thought you know
thinking about anger has been going on
in the west really since uh you know
ancient Greek philosophy and we can say
also drama and religious texts so you
know there's a lot to to evaluate and
there's plenty as well in the modern era
um you know Adam Smith and and Jeremy
Bentham and and you know Joseph Butler
and people like that as well and one of
the things that she's going to do in
this is talk about how we can understand
and classify anger and its drives what
it is that anger actually wants and so
she's going to make a distinction
between two main let's call them she
uses the word paths let's call them you
know
progressions uh by which we move from
being angry not being angry to being
angry and then doing things so one of
these is what she calls the path or Road
of
payback what anger does is it it sees
something that it considers to be wrong
that's been done and it's injurious to
oneself or to those that one cares about
and there's this sense that by doing
something to retaliate there'll be some
balance you know there'll be some uh
recalibration of how things work you
can't let people get away with that
right that's sort of the idea behind
payback and then she also notes that a
lot of anger has to do with perceived
status our our own status what we could
call our wave looking at ourselves or
self-image or self-esteem and the status
that is according to other people and
the Dynamics between those and so anger
often results from a perceived lowering
of a person's status or the status of
other things that they care about
including other people and then you get
angry and you retaliate in order to
lower the other person's status or raise
your own status now nbal thinks that
although this is how anger does work
this isn't good for us this is a this is
a real problem and we're you know the
payback idea really relies upon magical
thinking we can have what she calls
well-founded reasons for feeling angry
but we're not actually going to make
anything better by lowering other
people's status and to be you know too
obsessed with status is kind of a silly
way of living so what she actually
proposes is something that um she coins
a term for transition the transition or
sometimes transition anger and this is
when we do have this sense of an
injustice has been done something wrong
something uh that is inappropriate
however we want to frame it and we
realize that and we take steps in a more
rational way to address that we may get
angry at the start but we're not relying
on that anger as the driver for getting
the things done that need to get done
and we made do it in fact Without Anger
at all although that's somewhat rare and
so Nopal is actually
endorsing this uh transition and she'll
you know talk about it um to some
degree for example uh one of the the
first discussions of it is in the
section transition anger a rational
emotion anger
instrumental roles right and so she says
I'm going to make up a term it doesn't
focus on status nor does it even briefly
want the suffering of the offender as a
type of payback for the injury it
doesn't get involved in that type of
magical thinking it focuses on social
welfare from the start saying something
should be done about this it commits
itself to a search for strategies but it
remains an open question whether the
suffering of the offender will be among
the most appealing and then she she says
something quite interesting here is
transition anger a species of anger I
really don't care how we answer this
question so she's saying it's it's not
really that important that we say it it
stems from anger is it beginning in
Anger which is kind of a paradoxical
thing to say in a book about anger where
she's advocating transition anger right
uh what else can we say well she's got a
long discussion in entire chapter about
forgiveness and she wants to make the
claim that all too often forgiveness is
framed as something essentially
transactional meaning that I'll give
forgiveness if you meet these certain
conditions it can be a mode of
resentment trying to you know uh
retaliate against the other person by
humiliating them making them apologize
it can also go wrong as a transactional
thing in other ways and here's where
she's going to bring quite a bit of
religious literature in and talk about
for example the parable of the prodigal
son or uh M's uh Symphony uh which is uh
you know proposing we could say another
model um you know uh the uh uh here we
go the de the
um yeah uh composition introducing a a
resurrection without a judgment of
everybody is good or bad or things like
that so she is actually proposing either
unconditional
forgiveness or something that goes
beyond forgiveness
altogether generosity and love and you
know we'll we'll look in a bit whether
this is realistic enough enough of a way
of of approaching things it's certainly
her position uh we can go on she
discusses anger and a number of other
related emotions that we might want to
view as connected with anger but also
different from anger gratitude is one of
these and it's interesting because she
does note that um you know anger is
against people when they do things that
we perceive as bad to us or wrong to us
gratitude should be for doing uh things
to us that are good that are beneficial
or to other people who we care about she
also talks about grief she talks about
fear she talks about um resentment she
talks about all sorts of other possible
ways of us responding to situations and
you know this is I think quite important
in any discussion of anger because anger
doesn't occur completely in vacuum the
classic literature on anger going all
the way back to Aristotle does attempt
to distinguish it from other emotions
and to connect it with other emotions um
she talks about anger's instrumental
roles um for example early on in the
book in uh the the second chapter which
is on uh anger itself and she says anger
has three possibly useful instrumental
roles it can serve as a signal that
something is a miss right it can also uh
serve as motivation and you know so uh
allowing us to have the energy to do
things and then anger may also be a
deterrent when we see people getting
angry other people are like oh I don't
want to cross those lines with that
person I will you know refrain from
doing the wrong thing to them or to
others and while nbal wants to
acknowledge that anger May accomplish
these things there may be better
strategies for accomplishing these
things as well uh she also talks uh
quite a bit in the book about Divine
anger and this is where say lonus could
come up or you know ancient Jewish
scriptures talking about God's anger and
why talk about that at all well because
people have taken that as models for how
not only we you know how God ought to
behave or God does behave but how we we
human beings ought to behave and it
could also extend to forgiveness or to
generosity or to love or things like
that um there is also um you know some
some other important things anger is
typically going to be based in somewhat
wrong cognitions thoughts about things
judgments assumptions and it's also
going to stem from
um you know whether it's right or
wrongly perceived the the notion that
something wrong has been done Injustice
the sort of things that happen in
day-to-day life that happen in the
political realm that happen everywhere
else as well and then um you know it's
not easy to develop the right position
on anger and to embody it and I think
that's one thing that she does get
across in this we're going to fail
a lot we're not always going to be able
to like read a text like this and say oh
yes transition anger is the way I ought
to go right or no more uh transactional
forgiveness for me only unconditional
forgiveness that takes a lot of
reworking of our own psyche and habits
and assumptions and relationships um she
also is quite interesting in that she
she recognizes that her position is in
many respects um similar to that which
was classically articulated by stoic
authors but she wants to distinguish
herself from the stoics as well so for
example in her discussion of the middle
realm uh she says I will argue that in
this domain the stoics are basically
correct most of the things uh that we
get upset about are actually not worth
getting upset about it's a mistake to
make them the object of any serious
emotional concern but um you know she
also says my position is not stoic
because I hold that important
constituents of One's Own well-being are
vulnerable to damage by others who are
not our friends and loved one Health
bodily Integrity work and the health
safety integrity and work of people who
one loves it's appropriate I hold to
care a lot about these things um and so
you know she's she's interpreting the
stoics as if they don't care about those
things which is uh rather questionable
unfortunately um you know we can see as
well that she uh tells us this is in a
section called stoics on the middle
realm and she says the uh stoic critique
of anger rests on their sweeping
disparagement of the value of external
Goods things not under the control of a
person's reason and will they insist
that family and friends health Integrity
work and political standing have no
intrinsic value and they do not even
possess great
instrumental value now we'll we'll talk
about whether that's actually the stoic
position or not in just a bit but that
is uh her position so she's you know
positioning the stoics as I think we can
at one extreme when it comes to anger
all sorts of other people along a
Continuum and saying I'm not quite over
there I'm over here instead so those are
some of the key ideas motivating and and
articulated within this
book what are some of the particularly
positive characteristics about this book
what are the good points that we can
bring up before we start going into some
of the legitimate criticisms of the work
that we can raise well I mean it's
Martha NPO so you're going to get a good
book pretty much anytime that you go and
and you know acquire one of her texts
she may be off on some things but she's
going to be off in interesting and
wellth thought out ways that you can
certainly learn something from in the
process and she does get a lot of things
right and she does helpfully frame
things that's one reason why I have been
using this book as a textbook for class
during which the entire semester is
devoted to thinking about the emotion of
anger and so you know what we're going
to find in here are a number of good
introdu introductory level
analyses of you know classic thinkers
contemporary psychologists you know
literary um monuments we could say you
know she Begins by talking about the
amenities which you might or might not
have read if you haven't read it you
probably do want to read it because it's
pretty awesome or Meda in Greek tragedy
will come up a bit later on as well and
so you know you're going to get a a sort
of a good uh overview of interesting
thinkers who have something to say about
the emotion of anger and connected
emotions um there's quite a good one of
the things I really liked about this in
the literature on anger and this is a
little bit of a pet peeve of mine you
often see people wanting to say oh you
know uh we should actually view anger
not as something that that exists across
societies but is something that's more
culturally determined because there's
this tribe of Inuit uh the utku who are
studied in Jean Brigg's book never in
Anger right an anthropological study and
they'll say see anger doesn't have to be
in our life because these people view
anger as childish and they try to you
know get people to not feel it at all
and I think that nbel actually has quite
a good although short
examination of this um discussion that's
going on saying ah these claims
shouldn't be made so strongly notice
that they do view anger as childish a
threat to cooperation for group survival
in a very adverse climate uh anger in
children is tolerated but the experience
of anger and its outward manifestation
are viewed as inappropriate in adults
and you know then she she does sort of a
critical analysis about Brigg's own ex
you know engagements with them and says
Ah we can't conclude that much from it
so I think that's that's good um there's
a lot of good discussions of anger and
its relation to gender which is you know
in in classic literature I would say is
a tends to be a weak point um and is a
very important point for our present
right should uh should people who are
working for equality between uh men and
women and see that there is inequality
should they rely upon anger as fuel for
trying to reform institutions within
Society for calling out Injustice you
know these are some legitimate concerns
what are how are we vulnerable to each
other you know what way should we engage
with this and we could think about other
things as well you know when she gets to
the political discussions and we talk
about how do we view criminals uh who do
something that transgresses the Norms of
society and do hurt other people how
should we engage with them should we do
it through anger how should we think
about race particularly in situations
where hardcore racism both
individual and systematic and
intergenerational is imposing Injustice
on people you know for for Generation
after generation how do we use anger
then um I also do think that her
distinction between different Realms is
is a good approach to take you know so
we do have this personal realm and I I
think one of the strong points about
nb's treatment of these these Realms is
she says here's the characteristics of
relationships and how people view them
in this realm and here's why anger would
play itself out in these ways and here's
what might help with that and the
personal realm is different than say the
workplace right although some people
blur them together the workplace is part
of this middle realm that encompasses
all these other kinds of relationships
going to the uh store uh being she uses
an example of being uh on a plane
together with other people and having
you know men uh typically try to grab
her luggage and put it in the overhead
rack for her even though she says no
please I can actually handle my own
luggage and then we have the political
realm which includes how we live
together together in vast
societies this is a pretty decent way of
dividing up the topic I I think and and
quite
helpful there's a great uh discussion of
uh therapeutic literature we could call
it self-help literature as well having
to do with anger and I think that that
Nob is rightly suspicious of some of the
advocation of Ang
that goes on in this she says because
anger is a very large problem in
contemporary life a large therapeutic
literature on forgiveness focuses on how
people can free themselves from
obsessive and corroding anger right and
so you know in the process a common
device involves changing the way the
patient thinks of the for example
betraying spouse um and and she says you
know sometimes that's good sometimes not
so good right what if you are dealing
with a real jerk in your life you don't
want to suddenly become just empathetic
and compassionate towards them um
because that's going to make you
vulnerable to them um as I mentioned I I
I do use this as a textbook and I find
that it's a a good springboard for
discussions you know one of the things
that's nice about nbam besides the fact
that she you know where she's sometimes
wrong she's usually not 100% wrong and
she doesn't make huge unqualified
sweeping assertions about stuff it it
creates a environment a literary
environment in where in which we can
have some really productive
disagreements and discussions and say
all right what else could we say about
this where can we build upon this so I
think this is quite a good book in those
respects all right so what aspects of
this work do I find problematic I won't
go so far as to say actually bad but you
know things where you do have to make
some criticisms of nusb so one of the
things I'm going to say and perhaps this
stems from the kind of book that it's
intended to be nbalm is giving you a lot
of we could say introductory level
analysis of important uh
literature um psychology philosophy
religious text dealing with anger and
these other connected things but she
doesn't go very deep into it and some of
the time you get the impression
that although we know that she's you
know quite well read and uh learned that
she's kind of
coasting on previous studies of these
matters without really going back to the
text themselves and looking at them
carefully and
systematically so you can't use this as
a textbook by itself that'll give you
like
Aristotle's Fuller concept of anger or
um you know the stoics we're going to
talk about them in just a moment uh or
you know Joseph Butler who's a very
fascinating writer who has two really
important sermons discussing anger and
forgiveness you're only getting what she
thinks is useful for advancing the
general study and argument in the book
and that might not be enough for a lot
of readers and in my own classes I
supplement her work with lots and lots
of primary texts that we actually do
read about
anger um there's some significant gaps I
think in study you know she really
doesn't discuss Aristotle's predecessor
Plato who has a lot to say not as
systematically as Aristotle but a lot to
say about anger um she doesn't get into
other platonists like Plutarch who
actually have a lot to say as well you
know just little bits here and there but
no real exploration I think the
discussion of lonus is a little bit to
summary as well um you know we could go
on and on and on with with examples
where you're like oh man I wish she
would have gone deeper into this the one
really key thinker from the Middle Ages
who coins uh an idea that I think is
really helpful anger is being about the
difficult good Thomas aquinus doesn't
engage at all um so we could go on and
on about that and I don't really want to
do too much of that um I think that the
transition idea that she's expressing
here is a really good one I also think
that it could have used additional
fleshing out I think that that would
have benefited from you know doing some
case studies some
examples and framing it for people might
have actually been an entire appendix
devoted to like how do you do this if it
was going to be a more practically
useful text um I think that you know as
I mentioned I think this distinction
between the personal the political and
then what's in between is overall a good
way to approach things because they are
distinctive to each other but I do have
two main complaints one is that the
middle Realm
is just too multi
feris um I think that it should have
been broken down a bit more maybe there
should be you know more chapters devoted
to what's in between the upper level and
the level of individuals in individual
relationships and families and
friendships and things like that um I I
think that it could have used a lot more
discussion of
workplace and neighborhoods and and
things like that the the stuff that we
really do find ourselves in and it
probably would be great if the examples
that that she was using weren't drawn so
much from the experience of an upper
middle class Professor teaching at Elite
universities you know uh who is a baby
boomer and you know more let's say
relatable to the rest of us uh the
political Realm thing I think you know
it's important to to talk about anger in
politics but what's really disappointing
about this is that she devotes two
chapters to it one chapter is basically
just about criminal justice in the legal
system and the other is about what she
calls revolutionary Justice you know
changing things in you know fairly uh
unjust extreme situations like South
Africa segregation in the American South
and there's almost nothing about the
daytoday politics of
Elections uh or governance or the lower
level things which maybe fits into the
middle realm of not National politics
but local politics and all the other
things that are connected to politics
like
economics and education and we could go
on and on and on and on all of that's
missing politics in this book you would
think is basically just Criminal Justice
and um revolutions against what's what's
wrong you know there's really no
consideration of that now you could say
well the book came out in
2016 this is before the Trump era well
you know we had the politics of
resentment with the Tea Party long
before that didn't we and you could see
that anger was playing a major major
role at least in American politics
before the 2016 election so you wonder
you know what's what's uh motivating
these gaps there's also zero discussion
uh in any serious way of anger in social
media um you know in the internet in
general so you know there's some I would
say significant gaps of coverage here um
when it comes to that chapter at the end
on Revolution you know it's okay so it
it's great that we can talk about uh
Gandhi and Martin Luther King Jr and uh
Nelson Mandela and Desmond Tutu but you
know couldn't we find any more
contemporary um thinkers activists
causes to look at be you know more more
pressing things that we could analyze so
you know it's got a kind of dated feel
to it I mean what what nobal is handling
she's doing a good job with I would say
but you gota you got to kind of question
her choice of what she's
examining um we can also ask does she
actually get Aristotle right does she
get the stoics right and I'll pass over
the Aristotle thing I I will talk about
instead the stoics so who does she
actually engage as far as the
stoics basically just
senica and she's not actually doing much
more than looking at senica's book on
anger senica is a prolific author he
actually does treat for
example uh
generosity and forgiveness and um you
know uh
reciprocity and and things like that
gratitude in a book called on benefits
and in many of his letters she doesn't
engage that at all and so she doesn't
engage stoicism as such there's a little
bit of discussion of cipus there's a lot
of discussion of senica but mainly just
that one work she doesn't engage epicus
she doesn't engage Marcus Aurelius she
really doesn't engage the other
literature that we have uh about out
stoicism say in arys dimus or in uh
cisero or or other authors so you get
the idea that she's using Sena and
stoicism as kind of a foil rather than
adequately treating their work and so
you know very interesting case here is
where she's talking about grief um and
she says you know the the stoics they
think that that grieving is um not a
good
thing you know if there's any stoic for
whom we can say well there's some wiggle
room in his work compared to the others
when it comes to grief guess who it is
it's senica it's just not in on anger so
I I kind of think that she's not doing
like aade scholarship maybe not even
b-grade when it comes to her
criticism of the stoics and I do also
want to point something out she's got
this appendix anger and its
species which you know and we can we can
forgive um you know uh typos she has a
typo here about orge where it's uh this
is a Greek word that's used for anger
right and she she tells us that the
stoics you know considered anger mostly
As or and then it's got an extra e in it
somebody wasn't actually doing their
editing work properly in this let's
understand it's it's the the you know
last one so maybe that's the case but
she says stoics categorize anger org is
their generic term as it is Aristotle's
that's wrong Aristotle uses oray a lot
he also uses thumos sometimes
synonymously it's hard to picture
somebody as great a scholar as Martha
nusb of of classic philosophy screwing
this up right so you wonder what's going
on there the stoics do not actually use
orate as their generic term all we got
to do is go to Aras dimus or to diyes
leras or she even brings up you know
Cicero tuscal and disputations and we
find that the stoics distinguished a
number of different types of anger orgay
being one of them thumos being another
and then others being mixed in there as
well so you're you're like what what's
going on here this is not really careful
scholarship where is she getting this
stuff from so those are some some
significant issues there is one other
thing that I'm going to point out is a
quibble you know looking at the index
there's all sorts of interesting names
in here I kind of feel like some of the
entries in the index have been let's
call it plumped out to try to make it
and it didn't need to do this to make it
seem a little bit more engaging and
scholarly way of The Thinker so here's
Hegel right Hegel is supposed to be
showing up on pages 134 and
135 so you'd expect there to be like an
actual discussion of hegel's views and
Hegel actually does have views on the
passions and then what does she end up
saying you know here's here's it um of
increasing importance to me over time is
a point well made by Hegel taking note
of the special Clash of right with right
that a tragic situation presents may
help us well to think about the future
trying to create a future where such
clashes do not face well-intentioned
people I still believe marking the
difference between tragic choices and
other situations of choice is extremely
important and that hegel's
forward-looking account of that
importance at any rate is powerful what
is that she doesn't tell us how does
that work she doesn't tell us what work
would you find that in she doesn't
doesn't tell
us
so where is this coming
from who knows so I think that that's a
problem uh a minor problem granted but
you know it it if she's gotten in the
index Hegel a bit mixed up about this
who else is getting entries that aren't
really entries uh that that you know
where you would expect a serious
discussion to be taking place that isn't
isn't happening we don't know so that's
that's enough about the problematic
aspects of the
work all right so some final thoughts
about the work you know it's an
important contribution to contemporary
discussions about anger in a number of
ways as you can tell I think that it's
got some serious flaws to the the work
itself but overall a you know a decent
book decent enough for for me to use as
a textbook in my classes and to have my
students purchase although they probably
sell it afterwards um and I think you
could learn quite a bit by taking Martha
nbal as your interlocutor she's aidite
she's interesting she's uh great at
articulating arguments there are some
serious gaps within the coverage of the
work but it doesn't pretend to be an
Omnibus about anger altogether and so I
think that this could be useful for you
for thinking about these topics and then
going beyond the limitations of this
book